in 2014 Russian President Vladimir Putin
was not very popular among Republicans
or Democrats which made sense given his
a somewhat murderous strongman with the
nasty habit of invading his neighbor's
this is without question our number one
geopolitical foe breaking news signs of
a Russian invasion in Ukraine tonight
since 2025 journalists have died under
mysterious circumstances the Russian
military campaign in Syria after a week
of airstrikes now escalating
dramatically to prop up Syrian President
Assad this chart shows Putin's net
favorability among Republicans that's
the percentage of people who view him
favorably minus the percent who view him
unfavorably you can see the net
favorability begin to rise steadily
through 2014 and 2015 and then all of a
sudden in August 2016 it spikes by
December 2016 the share of Republicans
who saw Putin favorably had more than
tripled his popularity fell among
Democrats but by a much smaller margin
so what's going on here and what does it
mean for the United States relationship
with Russia what I think we're seeing is
two years of constant Republican
propaganda about how Vladimir Putin is a
strong leader who decides what he wants
to do and he does it in half a day it
makes a decision and he executes it
quickly then everybody reacts that's
what you call a leader people are
looking at Putin as one who wrestles
bearers and drills for oil they look at
our president as one who wears mom jeans
what you see it's just this Republican
talking point that builds and builds and
builds it finally really hits a peak
with Donald Trump I think I would get
along very well with him I respect Putin
is a strong leader if he says great
things about me I'm gonna say great
things about him I've already said he is
really very much of a leader I mean you
can say oh isn't that a terrible thing
he called him and the man has very
strong control over a country what we're
seeing with Donald Trump is that he
believes in the great man theory of
history both the great part of it and
also the man part of it he's a man who
sees himself as a tough decisive leader
authoritarian if necessary but willing
to do whatever it takes to push through
what he think needs to be done
I looked up gladly Putin Russia someone
who is made clear if you're dissident
and criticizes him you may disappear if
you're someone the public who isn't
fully in support of him you may lose
your job he looked at them things it
works
there is also a financial connection
Trump has had trouble getting loans from
US banks following his multiple
bankruptcy filings since 1991 we know
from a speech that his son Donald Trump
jr. made in 2008 that Russian investors
have played a big role in financing
Trump projects ever since most wealthy
Russian businesspeople maintained warm
relationships with Putin who holds
absolute power in the country
that means the investors who helped save
Trump's business empire are likely to
include several close Putin allies one
this extraordinary moment where a US
president is potentially financially
pulled into an enemy country led by
dictator
there is also an intelligence report in
which a former British spy claims that
the Russian government has compromising
information on Trump information that
they could use to blackmail him this
isn't Hollywood this isn't conspiracy
this isn't paranoia this may actually on
some level be true Republican voters
might be taking their cues from Trump
when it comes to Putin but Republican
lawmakers are a different story
Vladimir Putin as a person who's killed
he's jailed and murdered journalists
political opponents Putin is an
aggressor that does not share our
interests that are in Putin is violating
the sovereignty of neighboring countries
it certainly appears that he is
conducting in state-sponsored cyber
attacks on what appears to be our
political system the Russians are
undermining democracy throughout the
entire world they're taking land owned
by others by force they did hack into
our political system they're doing it to
other political systems before he was
Donald Trump's vice president then
representative Mike Pence held a similar
position and now an increasingly
antagonistic Russia has been rewarded
for bullying and threatening its
neighbors seven years later he was
singing a different tune I think it's in
arguable
that Vladimir Putin has been a stronger
leader in his country than Barack Obama
has been in this country when Trump
praises Putin he's also flouting his
party's long history of skepticism
towards Russia we think of Republicans
and the kind of leader that they
venerate it's Ronald Reagan they come
back to Reagan again and again and again
I remember when Ronald Reagan was the
president he stood on principle standing
up to the Soviet Union Ronald Reagan
reignited the American economy rebuilt
the military bankrupted the Soviet Union
and defeated Soviet Communism
and they come back to him because they
think he won the Cold War and because
they think he beat the Soviet Union the
march of freedom and democracy which
will leave Marxism Leninism on the ash
heap of history as it has left other
tyrannies which stifle the freedom and
muzzle the self-expression of the people
this is not just a break with
Republicans on the hill in 2016 this is
a break with the last 30 years in
Republican ideology dating back to the
President Ronald Reagan that they hold
up as a mere a god-like figure Trump has
also been slow to accept the CIA and FBI
is conclusion that Russia sought to
influence the presidential election
Russia hacked the Democratic National
Committee servers had hacked the
personal email John Podesta Hillary
Clinton's campaign chairman as far as
hacking I think it was Russia but I
think we also get hacked by other
countries and other people
Vladimir Putin weaponized the fact that
we have a free press he used WikiLeaks
to kind of launder the information and
then dribbled it out day by day by day
so four weeks in Iran for the election
all you saw was negative press coverage
of Hillary Clinton driven by selectively
chosen leaked emails in response
President Obama issued economic
sanctions against Russia which Donald
Trump doesn't have to keep these were
weak these sanctions they're gonna do
nothing Vladimir Putin will look at this
and say I got what I wanted I can pay
this cost I'll do it again
[Music]
you